[Music]
hello everyone and
welcome to a rather impromptu video uh
which came about
in the last couple of weeks i've been
getting a lot of questions
on my twitch stream uh from
people who learned and got interested in
chess in the last couple of months
you know by watching queen's gambit or
by watching pog champs
and um as over-the-board chess is
resuming
as tournaments are starting to resume
the summer and certain chess clubs in
various cities are picking up their
operation
um i think a lot of people want to get
into over-the-board chess
and you know they want to play a
tournament see what it's like to play an
actual
uh irl chess tournament or maybe join
their local city chess club or find out
if they their city has
a local chess scene and so i've been
getting a lot of questions from people
who really who don't know where to start
uh because you know if you want to play
an over-the-board chess tournament
you have to become a member of the
united states chess federation and
uh you know your eyes can kind of glaze
over at that which websites you need to
go to how do you even find
a tournament listing what is the
difference between an online rating and
a
uh you know official over the board
rating so i've been getting a lot of
these questions and i figured that
i'd make a totally unorganized
unscripted
video where i uh walk you through some
of the steps
that you should take if you want to make
a foray into over-the-board chess
so a couple of things that i'll be
talking about uh we'll start on the
homepage of the united states chess
federation
and i'll walk you through the process of
becoming a member uh and how to find a
tournament listing
then we're going to take the micro view
and i'll talk about how
uh to find whether your local city has a
chess scene and
how to find tournaments in your state i
know that i have a lot of international
viewers as well so
please don't feel excluded i'll be
talking also about fide
and what it means to be a member of feed
a few day rating
and how to find tournaments
internationally so a lot of the advice
that i will be giving is of course
very much applicable uh to wherever you
live and wherever you are
uh again this will be a totally
non-exhaustive overview
i'm sure that i'll leave a lot of
questions unanswered
and i would encourage you to post more
questions in the comments section
i plan to make a couple of a couple more
of these types of videos if this one
goes around well
uh where i'll talk about the
over-the-board tournament experience
i'll answer other uh commonly you know
address other common misconceptions so
this will be part of a series of
of videos but it's entirely experimental
so
cut me a little bit of slack and so
without further ado let's jump in
and let's start on the homepage of the
united states chess
federation which is commonly abbreviated
uscf
let me just switch to my window browser
tab here we go
and let's go to the us chess website
it's uschs.org
and here you are so if you want to play
an official over-the-board tournament
in the united states the vast vast
majority of tournaments
require you to be a uscf member in order
to join
now how do you become a uscf member well
that's pretty easy you navigate over to
join
you click become a member and um
you would enter all of your information
i'm not going to enter my address don't
worry
now below you can select the particular
option that you're looking for if you're
not
entirely sure whether you want to keep
this chest thing going you'd select one
year
and i would highly recommend that you
that you select the
small additional charge for chest life
which is the official magazine of the
united states chess federation
it's jam-packed with cool information
it's got tournament reports it's got
annotated games
it's got information about upcoming
tournaments as well so
i personally would highly recommend it
if you're absolutely sure that chess is
going to play a big role in your life
for many years to come
then definitely select a lifetime
membership
either 64 and under 65 and over this is
definitely a pretty good deal okay
now once you have filled out the form
and made the appropriate payment you
will be given
a member id remember id is very
important that is what's going to be
used to register
for tournaments now you don't need to
write down
your id in a safe place this isn't like
your bitcoin wallet password because
if you want to find the id of an
existing member
then you would navigate over to ratings
click the players rating lookup and you
can search
any member any player who is a member
current member of the uscf current or or
expired actually i think this has very
exhaustive information
you can search by member id but the
easiest is to search by name
now can i remember any gm's any people
who are members of the uscf
i heard about this one guy you certainly
don't want to deal with him
it's just that i'm going to search him
because i don't know anybody else i
don't even want to say this person's
name
so let's see um and this takes takes a
while to
load i think it's going through a huge
just massive database of players
and well there i am you can see my
rating and
all the information the state date of
expert i better renew my membership
pretty soon uh
and if you click on on the name itself
it redirects you to a page
where you can find uh all of my
tournament information if you click on
tournament history you can see all of
the tournaments i've played
uh basically since you know since uh
since
early 1990s it has exhaustive tournament
records
you can navigate over and see that i
played my first tournament in 2003
uh where i was granted a rating of 803
so
i was not born a gm and you can do that
with every with anybody who is a member
of the uscf
and you know if you would write if you
register you're going to have an
empty tournament page because you
presumably wouldn't have played any uh
over-the-board tournaments
but this member idea before your name
that's what you basically want to be
uh aware of and that's all there is to
it that's how to become a member of the
uscf
now um let's say that you you know
you've paid for the membership
uh what do you do now so since we're
already on the us chess
website what you would want to do next
is navigate over to play
and to view the tournament calendar and
this tournament calendar is not entirely
exhaustive it doesn't include
every little local tournament but it
does include the vast majority
you can click upcoming tournaments and
you can do whichever search
you want you can search by state um you
can search
uh you know a date range let's say you
uh have a couple of weeks off of work in
july and you want to play a tournament
somewhere in in july
what you would do is you would enter
these search fields and
let's say you you didn't you could
travel you can click apply
and it will take you through all of the
tournaments
okay i think it didn't fully update
um let's see me
yeah i guess no i guess it is updated
it's just these these tournaments seem
to be uh
weekly tournaments that will be held in
july and
uh you can basically see all of the
tournaments that will be held in that
rating range now still uh some over the
board tournaments are resuming other
tournaments are going to be held online
so make sure that uh the tournament you
click on and and you plan is an over the
board tournament
now you can see here the 49th annual
world open
this is uh one of the biggest open
tournaments
held annually in the united states it's
got a huge prize fund
and you've maybe even heard of it it's
held every year in philadelphia
now if you click on the tournament
listing you're going to be taken to this
page which is a huge block of text now
don't be overwhelmed by this
it's just a whole lot of technical stuff
and a lot of boilerplate
what this basically tells you what's
important here are the dates
and the location of course and then it's
got information about sections and
prizes now
most uh large-ish tournaments in the u.s
have rating sections the top section is
usually the open section where
all of the grand masters play and by
definition anybody could play in the
open
um sometimes there's lower rating
restrictions but generally speaking
people over 2200
uh so masters and above play in the open
and in these big tournaments
there's uh section increments every 200
points so there's under 2200 under 2 000
uh under 18 1600 1400 and if you are
playing your very first
uh tournament over the board tournament
you would register in the under 1100
unrated section
and i'll talk about how to register in
just a second so the interesting thing
is that with this chess boom
you've had a lot of players who uh you
know who've
gained a lot of experience playing
online and so their a rating might be
you know 17 1800 online but they haven't
played a tournament so
my guess is that this summer these
unrated sections are going to be
absolute bloodbaths and you're going to
have players whose
real strength is you know 16 1700 uh
playing over the board so it's going to
be really interesting
but nonetheless you would play in the
unrated section no matter what your
online rating is
and as i'll discuss in a moment
your uscf rating is totally distinct
from
whatever rating you have on
leadchesterchess.com disregard that
uh your official uscf rating is what's
counted
uh when you enter tournaments and when
pairings are are made
so you can see all the prizes uh for the
corresponding section so even for the
unrated section the top prize is three
thousand dollars the world open is a
serious tournament
uh and you can check also the entry fees
for each
section they're usually pretty pricey uh
but the world opens a huge tournament so
the entry fee here is going to be a lot
more expensive
than the entry fee for some local
tournament that you might that you might
want to play
now let's say that you like this and you
want to register now what do you do
at the bottom of the tournament listing
there's generally going to be a link to
a
more specified website where you can do
the registering
the continental chess association is uh
the
association that sort of organizes the
world open
now do not be confused all of these
tournaments that i'm talking about
they're all
uh usc uscf rated so they're held under
the auspices of the united states chess
federation it's just that
this the continental chess association
refers to the particular organizer of
the tournament
it's not a separate uh kind of like a
chess it's not like the nba and aba
it's just uh it refers to the organizer
these tournaments are all
uscf rated so make sure some of these
websites are not
uh have not been updated since um you
know since the uh
battle of antatum so make sure that you
are you know very very careful you
navigate over to the proper tournament
don't click you know the bradley open
unless you want to play that
so let's say you wanted to play the
world open um
where i see you and i can't find there
it is world open you would click enter
now
so let's say you want to register you
would click enter now okay
again you have to hunt it down now most
of these tournaments have side
tournaments you can play the world open
warm-up
or if you're a senior you can play a
senior amateur
so you can hunt around in these sites as
well but um
not the world open action just the world
open
uh and there's usually a speed chest or
a blitz tournament that's uh
held the night or or the day of the last
round you can register for that as well
but if you want to play one of those
side tournaments you would usually do
that registration on site
okay so you would click buy one now
and this takes you to the registration
page all registration pages for
tournaments are different but they all
ask you to provide the same thing
you have a uscf id you would search your
own name
so let's say i was trying to register
you know
search my name you know click on
click on your name and blah blah blah
you enter your address and
all your information and then you know i
only can register it in the open section
because i'm a gm
so i'm not eligible dang i was going to
play in the under 1100 and
uh stack some cash but unfortunately
won't let me do that but for you if you
didn't have a rating it would
essentially direct you to the
appropriate section now
as a lower rated you could technically
play in a higher section that is called
playing up
that's when somebody let's say who's
1200 does not play in the under 1400
section
but let's say chooses to play in the
under 1800 section if you're playing
your very first tournament
and uh you know your goal is to gain a
little bit of experience i do not
recommend playing up you're gonna end up
playing a lot of very high rated players
and uh if you don't have a lot of over
the board experience it might not be the
best
idea to do that straight away and that's
essentially how you register for
uh for a tournament that's how you hunt
down tournaments on a national scale
so just to recap you would go if we go
back to the us chess federation website
you would go to the play tab and then
click upcoming tournaments
if you want to hunt down just the really
big tournaments the tournaments that
attract grandmasters and have a lot of
sections
you can click the national events
calendar and this basically just shows
you all of the big ticket events
uh what's coming up a lot of you know is
the national open this just
a couple of days from the time the video
is recorded i've played in this
tournament many times perhaps some of
the
some of you viewers are playing in this
tournament maybe this is even your first
tournament if so
congratulations and you can hunt down
really the big tournaments here and you
can plan well ahead
so uh but to look at all of the
tournaments you would collect upcoming
tournaments now if you're
a young player if you're a parent to a
kid who
and you want him or her to get into
chess you can
hunt down you mean you can explore
international youth events
uh us open so these are various
tournaments that you can kind of
uh that you can kind of call by by age
the danker for example is the annual uh
national tournament of of heist of top
rated high schoolers they basically
choose the top rated player from each
state
uh and invite them to one uh big
tournament so
the 2020 danker champion is a grand
master grandmaster nicholas checker
and that's right about uh all there is
to it
you can also play around on this website
there's a lot of really good links
and resources that you could that you
could find
um now let's take a more micro approach
and let's talk a little bit about how to
find
resources for chess in your city or your
town or a place of residence
now um if the year was 1967
and your name was for example beth
harmon how would beth harmon find where
to play chess and her
i think she's uh from kentucky how would
she find
her local chess club well uh you would
have to use
your copy of chess life it was back then
called chess review
um and as i mentioned is the monthly
magazine of the
uscf uh many years ago the us
the the chess review magazine would
publish uh the tournament listing and it
would also publish a listing of
uh chess clubs by city uh unfortunately
maybe if only i had like a old copy of
chess review lying around somewhere i
would be able to show you
wait a second i just might let's take a
look here
1967 outfitting
june this is uh wow
i didn't even realize that bobby fisher
on the cover here so let's take a look
now you can see here there
is a comprehensive tournament calendar
by city and let's see if i can uh
show this on on camera with okay i'm not
even seeing what i'm showing you but
here we go
you can see canada denver and this is
almost exactly the same as the modern
listing on the us chess federation
website all the prize funds and
prizes and the address so you had all of
that
just in the uh in the indie chess
review magazine and then at the end you
would have let's see here
you would have a listing and the
magazine is falling apart so
it's a little bit hard to navigate this
over to the camera but you guys can see
um it basically lists all of the cities
and
all of their respective chess clubs it's
a little bit blurry but you can see
now i wouldn't use 1967 chess review 2
and then visit the the address listed on
on on the on the page some of these
chess clubs of course still exist the
marshall chess club in new york is a
great example
uh the berkeley chess club but most of
them are either defunct or they move to
a different address
so back then you would use chess review
but nowadays you have at the internet
and the internet has all of the
resources that you need to hunt down
your local chess scene so if we go back
to
that wonderful place called google
all right so let's see let me go back to
my window browser tab
and let's make a new tab here and let's
go
google and let's say for a hot second
that you
are that you live in the state of
indiana let's choose a random state
uh the first thing i'd recommend that
you do is most states
have their own dedicated sort of a
sub-chess federation so in the nhs
federation california chess federation
north carolina chess association
so you would want to start there because
essentially that page will often contain
a link
to a page that has a listing of all of
the chess clubs and chess scenes in your
state
so if we go to the indiana state chess
association okay so you you can follow
the links here there
often there will be a tournament listing
uh four tournaments in your state
uh so for example in indiana you can
play in the northern indiana
open reserve this is a smaller
tournament but you can still see
uh that there are probably like one or
two sections
and of course the prices are much
smaller so you can you know to register
you have to go to this link but on this
particular website you can click the
clubs button
and it will basically show you a
relatively comprehensive listing of all
the chess clubs in your state now one
really interesting thing to see uh i
think some people think that the uscf
kind of
has a club chapter in every big city
that's really not how it works
uh in chess basically every city fence
for itself uh and what you'll see is
that some very big cities
really have a very scant chess presence
there's no unified chess club
and then you might find that a very
small town has a big and flourishing
chess club
and you kind of see that here
indianapolis the largest city
uh has you know doesn't even really have
a chess club as far as i know there's
just some like chess
meeting in the university uh but you
know some
small towns like you know south bend is
not that small but it
seems to have a chess club what you'll
see is that many of these chess clubs
meet in a cafe or restaurant
um actually quite a few of them
or not a lot of them just a few of them
have a dedicated space it's quite rare
for a chess club to have a dedicated
space so don't be
uh don't be scared off if the chess club
meets in a restaurant that's very
typical
and um for some of these chess clubs you
can click on
the web the website and some of these
chess clubs will have dedicated websites
and um try to figure out what it is that
you're looking for because some chess
clubs they will have a weekly meetup
where um you know everybody will meet in
that cafe
uh and you'll walk in you'll see a bunch
of people with chess boards and they'll
be playing casual chess and talking
chess
and if you're just getting into chess
that's the kind of meetup that i'd
recommend
uh and none of the speed chess games
that are being played there
are are officially rated this is just
for fun now some chess clubs
like the charlotte chess center
they have weekly official games so the
charlotte chess center has the tna
tuesday night action so every tuesday
night
uh you can come and you can play a uscf
rated game
you can just walk in and if you're a
uscf member you can register to be a
member of the charlotte chess center
and uh you'll be able to play a rated
game
what you would want to do is you would
want to check if your local city chess
club has
such an offering so let's take another
random city let's take denver let's see
denver chess club
denver i think does have a a dedicated
okay so it's located in
a church which is quite common uh for
chess clubs
and uh you can click tournaments so you
can see what tournaments are being
offered
and dcc that that almost sounds like one
of those weekly events
let's click on that and see where it
brings us
um no that's a that's a one day
tournament so that's a
it's a one day tournament but you can
essentially uh
you can look arrested club information
ah it seems like tuesday is a very
popular day for like
chess meetups in general weekly meetings
are held tuesday night
uh so you could walk in at 6 30 pm on
tuesday and you would see
either they're playing casual games or
maybe there's a casual game
games being played in one corner and
then there's like players who want to
play official rated games
see so just about every week that denver
chesco hosts classical rated games
that's pretty common for more
you know more unified chess clubs uh but
if you find that your city doesn't have
a a clear you know meeting chess club
then
you know the next best thing is to go to
the website of your state's
chess association in fact that's where i
would start
then i would go to the club listing on
that page
most states chess federations will have
that kind of page
and um if that's not satisfactory then
you can directly search
your city followed by chess club and see
if
there is any kind of chess scene so
that's a little bit about how to find
tournaments on a
larger scale and then how to explore
your local
city chess scene now there's one more
thing that i wanted to talk about before
i
uh summarize fide and then wrap up
and that is i recently found a very
interesting
website it's called it literally is
called chess dash site.com
and uh let's say for example that you
you have a kid who you want to involve
in a chess program you want to find
chess camps or chess academies
this is a good listing of some of these
chess academies and chess camps
uh that i found and you can see here the
charlotte chess center is listed you can
see the berkeley chess school
so uh the berkeley chess school is very
active in local schools
uh and uh this is a list of chess camps
and chess academies
which are geared mostly for kids and and
younger
uh players but even if you're an adult
you could definitely explore and
sometimes these chess academies they
will host adult classes like
the charlotte chess center in
pre-coveted times would host
an adult class every thursday and if you
click for example the website of the
berkeley chess school
or let's actually just go to their
website directly
you will see that uh
you know the berkeley chess school host
terms and you can see the bcs summer
camp 2021 in person
uh so there is a chess camp and there's
actually quite a few chess camps in the
summer
so if you have a kid who's particularly
interested in chess consider enrolling
them in a chess camp that is
uh you know i guarantee you if your kid
likes chess
they will have a blast at a chess camp i
can totally not biased
but really it it is a a very good uh
place to to send your kid
if if they're into chess so you can read
about this berkeley chess school
camp and some camps are actually sleep
away camps some camps are
you know half day camps but in any case
you can explore
uh all of these chess academies and
chess camps to maybe find a chess camp
or chess academy in your city
um a lot of the bigger cities have
dedicated chess academies
that may or may not be affiliated with
you know the local chess club so the way
to understand this is
the chess organizations are very descent
decentralized you have the u.s chess
federation
and then you have all these sort of just
academies and
organizers every every tournament is is
uscf rated but
there isn't this sort of one unified
organization you have to hunt and pick
and find
different sources of information and
finally let us transition to a more
international scale
and let us go to the homepage of fije
which is of course the international
chess federation the reason it's called
fide that's a
french language acronym federation
international addishekh
i think is what it stands for which
means international chess federation
and i i don't know why um you know it is
it has come to be known fije by fide
rather than icf i think that's just
historical
but that is what it stands for so this
is the homepage of feeding
and you can basically do on fidei
exactly the same thing that you can do
on uscf
except on an international scale so if
you live in europe or if you're
traveling to europe
you can click calendar and the website
is a little bit maybe a little bit less
user-friendly but it's easy
to navigate nonetheless and you can
click uh the month let's say you're
traveling to europe with your family in
august and
you want to see what tournaments are on
offer this is a pretty comprehensive
list
there are dedicated chess calendars you
can google search which have more
comprehensive listings of tournaments
this basically has all the big stuff you
can see list the country list the
tournament
uh you know if you will happen to be in
uh scaliza slovakia you can play in the
scaliza chess festival
and this list all of the same
information beautiful and i kind of want
to
again i want to play there now and uh
you know basically it will give you the
the official website through which you
will have to register
uh now i should mention that most
tournaments in europe that are nine
rounds
so here you can see the number of rounds
quite often you will have only one game
a day in europe
so tournaments generally take a week
plus but if not all of them some
you know they have short tournaments but
in in america if you have a nine round
tournament usually there will be two
games a day
so that the schedule is a lot more
grueling uh because generally
tournaments are fitted
really to only last a long weekend so
even the world open
uh the longest you can play different
sections you can play four day three day
and then eventually they all merge
together but the very longest section is
you know only four days so that's just
something to factor in as well but you
can always see
the start and end dates of these
tournaments so you can click on calendar
and
uh you can you can navigate around and
you know if you want to play a blitz
tournament
in europe uh there aren't too many over
the world bliss tournaments scheduled
right now but here's another one in
slovakia
um and another one in slovakia wow lots
of lots of tournaments in slovakia
i've actually never played in slovakia
but i'd love to i'd love to visit so you
can find those as well
other cool stuff that you can do on the
feed a website well before i get to that
um i want to talk for a second about
ratings so
if you've registered as a member of the
usc if you played a tournament you got a
usc up rating
now for all intents and purposes you do
not have to worry about getting a feed a
rating
fee day ratings and uscf ratings are
completely two different kettle of fish
so what you see here magnus is rating or
if you search this this
anonymous and terrible gm again you'll
see that i'm 2621
feed a rating but if you search my usc
operating it's like almost 2700
that's because these are two separate
formulas and not
all tournaments which are uscf rated are
also feed a-rated
so what happens is that when you play
let's say the world open
the only section of the tournament that
gets submitted for a fee day rating
is the open section the section that has
all the grand masters if you play the
under 1600 or you play the unrated
section
you are not going to get a feed a rating
uh so
and it's actually quite uncommon for a
country to have its own rating system
that's as active as the uscf
uh so there's only a brit you know great
britain canada i think has its own
rating system most european countries do
not have their own
internal rate that doesn't mean they
don't have their own chess federations
it's just the chess federations don't
have their own rating system
so if you're starting to play chess in
slovenia
you will automatically immediately get a
feed a rating even if you play in your
local
city tournament so that's just the way
that it is it's not good or bad
um and some you know you might end up
getting a feed a rating if you get good
and you start playing in the open
section of a tournament
your tournament will get submitted to
feed a no action is required on your
party you don't need to register
to be a member of fide you automatically
uh essentially as far as i know maybe
the regulations have changed but as far
as i know
no action is required you will
automatically get a feed a rating
and you will have a listing on this page
and be able to search your rating once
you play in a feed a rated tournament at
first your rating will be
provisional uh and once you play a
couple of tournaments your rating will
stabilize but unless you're a
grandmaster trying to qualify for
tournaments and then you would
wouldn't really have any use of this
video anyway you do not have to worry
about getting a feed a rating or
or stressing about it at all but you can
search uh anybody's rating look at the
top 100 players you can look at
uh all of the players in the country if
you live uh in
you know any country you want to check
who the top players in your country are
fide is a great resource for this
they uh they change the website so i
am actually having a little oh there we
go so you can click the top fed button
top federations
and um it lists the average rating of
the top 10.
you can go all the way down you can
click you know you live in uh morocco
you can click moroccan you can see oh
morocco has a as a grandmaster hicham
hamduchi now the
federation of the player doesn't always
correspond to the country of residence
hamdu she lives in
france i think but uh you can look up
all the top players of your country so
one thing is if you live in a country
uh and you know you're having a hard
time uh getting to
your country's chess federation uh but
you
you wanna in person coach uh one
interesting hack is you could look up
the top players in your country and you
could try to track down
uh somebody who might not have a big
online presence you might find that they
live in your
if you live in the capital city uh you
might try to send them an email
or find their contact and they might be
willing to give you in-person lessons
so that would be one use of that and
it's also just interesting to be aware
of who the top players in your country
are so that's another interesting thing
you could do
but by and large you know you can click
the directory and uh or contacts you can
email
um the me for immediate inquiries and
you could email the feed a president i
don't think you'll get a response
but you can find all of this stuff on
the international chess
federation page and um
that's about all i had for this video
i've already been blabbering for 30
minutes so i think that's
probably more than sufficient uh if this
video
is well received i will make more video
i mean i'll probably make more videos
anyway
where i talk about different aspects of
the over-the-board chess experience
and i want to talk you know address
other misconceptions about
over-the-board chess so this will be a
series i know that i've
not addressed a lot of things and you
are more than welcome
really encouraged to leave comments uh
where you clarify
or ask questions and i will do my very
very best for this video
to browse the comment section and
address specific questions on the basis
of
uh what i talked about today so i hope
uh that i was able to at least
partially demystify the process of
getting
active and over-the-board chess and
explain some of these tricky and thorny
concepts that kind of just get
thrown around a lot uh and i i thank
everybody for listening i know it's been
a pretty long video so
let's close off for now thanks again for
listening
feel free to leave questions and uh
other advice and topics to discuss in
the comments section
and i'll keep uploading the speedrun
videos in the next couple of days
thank you very much i will see you in
the next video
[Music]
goodbye